enfant on nous a appris que cette règle
d'or signifiait sois gentil mais nous ne
sommes plus des enfants et puis qu'il va
nous falloir plus que les casseurs de
grève pour tous les mines fonctionnent à
nouveau parler de vous voir tous comme
des individus et considérez vous plutôt
comme un soleil nico les laisser voler
vos fermer vos maisons ce n'est pas
acceptable
décédé à des banques à des hommes
d'affaires qui vous traite comme des
chiens ce n'est pas acceptable
est-ce qu'on va réagir mon nom
un silence furieux rugissants
assourdissant est-ce que vous l'entendez
je veux voir s'abattre affluent de grève
et le blocage
cette grève des fermiers est terminée on
va montrer à cette ville l'impuissance
visionner
dans la baronne dédié une révolution ici
nous sommes obligés de la femme et toute
la région pendant 40 jours et 40 microns
soit respectée là
ainsi soit il
[Musique]